The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I'm
going to give you
a quick example of what I think
is a good way to do solutions.
Our approach to solutions.
State the problem.
I'm going to give you a
little formulaic here.
Draw figures.
On the first day I said I like
to think of dynamics problem.
I break them down
into three categories.
One is to describe the motion.
What does describing
the motion mean?
Well how many-- the
number of degrees of
freedom in the problem.
That implies the number
of equations of motion
that you're going to need
to solve that problem.
So you got to identify the
number of degrees of freedom.
It also then tells you the
number of coordinates you need.
So this is all part of
describing the motion.
It's figuring out how many
coordinates, assigning them.
So assigning the coordinates.
And then finally, essentially
all underneath this you
essentially do the kinematics.
And that's the velocities,
accelerations, so forth.
So once you have-- you've
explained the motion.
And this I guess is four.
Explain the correct
physical laws.
You know how they apply.
f equals ma.
Newton's first, second, third
law of conservation of momentum
or whatever you want-- you
think is the appropriate thing.
So explain what the physical
laws are and apply them.
And finally, do the math.
So if you could break
problems down that way
it'll give you a
nice, logical flow.
So I'm going to give you a
bit of an example problem.
And I'm also going to kind
of pose a brain teaser to you
at the end of this
problem today.
I want to give you
something to think about.
So I'm going to draw my problem.
This is a block on an incline.
It's got some scales
to measure your weight.
And you're standing
on this thing.
Riding it down the incline.
And the first
question about this
is to find the position
as a function of time.
So that's the problem.
That's part a.
So state the problem,
find the position.
So how-- well what do we do?
Well draw figures,
I've started with that.
Next, describe the motion.
I need a free-- We
have to figure out
how many degrees of
freedom this problem has.
I'm going to just
declare no rotation.
Going to treat it as a particle.
So a particle has how many,
generally how many degrees of
freedom?
How many coordinates
to completely describe
where it's at?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: Three.
So I may need as many
as three coordinates
to describe the
motion of this thing.
And if I really doing
complete equations of motion
I need three
equations of motion.
So this is two, three--
describing the motion I
have three degrees of freedom.
I'm going to need
three coordinates.
So in this case
here's my picture
I'm going just to set up a
Cartesian coordinate system
aligned in a helpful way.
X, y, z coming out.
And this is my fixed
inertial reference frame.
And here's my center of mass.
And basically my coordinates
are describing the position
of the center of mass.
So that's pretty much the
describing the motion,
what I need for now.
We'll get to the velocities
and accelerations
when we get to the math part.
Apply the physics.
I'm going to use
Newton's second law.
Sum of the external forces,
mass times the acceleration.
That's the physical
law I'm going to apply.
Draw a free body diagram.
And I'm just going
to consider the block
and the person this is the whole
collection, it's one thing.
I'm just not keep
drawing the person on it,
but-- so here's my
object, including
the weight of the person.
And it's going to have--
here's its center of mass.
Obviously in mg,
gravitational force,
it's going to have
a normal force.
Going to have a friction
force and how do I
figure out what the friction--
which direction the friction
is?
I assume motion down the hill.
Friction will oppose it.
I draw in the arrows
in the direction
I expect the forces to act.
Then I'll use the
sign convention
that the arrows
tell me what signs.
So since my x-coordinate
is down the hill.
This is y.
This is x, friction x,
in the minus x direction.
And I haven't-- I've left out
a key piece of information.
Got to have the
angle of the slope.
And once you have the angle
of the slope that's theta,
this is theta.
And I'm going to need to--
this is in a direction of one
of my coordinates
and so is this,
but I need to break
the gravitational piece
into components lined
up with my coordinates.
And so you have a
theta here as well.
And now I can write
my equation to motion.
And the nice thing
about vectors is
that when you have three
equations of motion,
three coordinates, each that
are components of vectors
in the x, y and z
direction, it gives us
three equations immediately.
So for example, the
summation of the forces
in this problem in
the z-direction,
the external forces are sums to?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
OK so we get a trivial
solution out of that.
And we don't have
to go much further.
Summation of the forces
in the y-direction
gives us some
useful information.
And then the y-directed forces
I have an n and a minus mg
and I think it's cosine theta.
Which tells me
immediately what n is.
So from statics I get to-- and
from what we know about models
of friction then we know that
we can model the friction as mu
times n for mu mg cosine theta.
So from the statics I
learn a bunch of things
that I need to know
for the problem.
So now I get to the real
heart of the problem,
writing my equation of
motion in the x-direction.
And the forces in
the x-direction mg
sine theta down the hill.
So it's positive.
Minus the friction
is up the hill.
So I get mg.
I'm mixing up my m's here but
there's no other m so-- this
basically says, that x double
dot, the m's all cancel out.
That x double dot is g sine
theta minus mu g cosine theta.
And that just happens to be
a pretty simple to solve,
ordinary differential equation.
This is an equation in which
the acceleration in the problem
is constant.
The data's not changing.
None of these
things are changing
and so you can just
solve this one.
Now we're to the third
part, do the math.
This one you can just integrate.
And so you find out
that well, x dot then
and I'm just going to
call this c some constant.
So x dot ct plus an initial
velocity, if it had one.
And x of t, what
you're looking for.
And now so v0 and x0 are
just your initial conditions.
More than likely 0 if
you set it up cleverly.
So that's just
modeling quickly what
I think a good way to
lay out a problem is.
Describing the motion,
explaining the physics,
doing the math, drawing good
pictures, stating the problem.
All right so now
the brain teaser
that I want you to think about.
So here's the mass of the
block plus the scales.
And here's the-- here
you're standing on it.
So mass of the person.
You're riding this
down the hill.
So this is part b.
Think about that
when in the shower.
If you've got a really
simple way to do it,
great write it up.
It's not terribly hard and it's
mostly-- I'll give you a hint.
Thinking in terms of free
body diagram helps a lot.
And we'll come back to
this kind of fun problem.
OK, want to go--
that was part one.
I want to go onto this recapping
the center of mass quickly.
We learned a couple
of important things.
We got-- we talked
about the center of mass
because we were just talking
about Newton's three laws.
From looking at the
first law, found
that it's useful in
determining whether or not
you're in a inertial
frame, we used it.
Second law we've
just applied it.
We used to do-- get
equations of motion.
Third law was about--
we used it when we're
thinking about center of mass.
We used it to define what
the center of mass was.
So we said the total
mass of a system,
I better draw my picture.
Here's my system of particles.
M1 with position vectors.
So a whole mess of particles
with their position vectors.
This is ri with respect
to O for example.
This is my O x, y, z frame.
We said that this total
mass of the particles
somewhere out here there's a
center of mass with a position
vector rg with respect to O.
So the definition of my center
of mass is this is equal to the
summation of the m, i, r, i, o
and these are position vectors.
So that's the definition
of my center of mass.
If I take two time derivatives
of that we arrived at mt rg
with the respect
to O double dot.
Summation over i of my m,
i, r, i, o double dots.
And then importantly
that's the summation
of all of the external
forces on each
of these-- each one
of these by itself
satisfies Newton's
law, second law, which
he wrote about particles.
Each one has a summation.
I've summed these and
I'm going to sum these,
but each one has a summation of
internal forces acting on it.
These I call the f, i, j's.
And we learn-- something
about the third law
tells us about that summation.
The third law tells us what?
That goes to 0 and that was
that's the really powerful
piece of the third law
that we make great use of.
Because this now essentially
allows us to say,
that the summation
of the external
forces on an assembly
of particles,
on a system of particles,
is equal to the total mass
times the acceleration
of the center of mass.
And that-- what that
does in one stroke
takes you from Newton, who's
laws applied to particles
and allows you to apply Newton's
second law to rigid bodies.
Because rigid bodies
can be thought up
a bunch of particles,
which are represented
in that simple equation.
And that gets you from
particles to rigid bodies.
And we all know from
physics that a summation
of the external
force on this thing
is the mass times
the acceleration
of the center of mass.
So that's actually quite
an important powerful law.
It provides this for us.
Now I said I wanted to
give you a quick, very
useful application of
thinking about center of mass.
I showed you the other day, I
had my carbon fiber tube here.
Showed you that trick for
finding the center of mass
just by sliding your
fingers along it.
And you end up at
the center of mass.
Well as a practical
matter other things--
you really want to be
able find center of mass.
This is a glider, a
sailplane called an LS8.
I happen-- I'm a glider
flight instructor.
Been flying gliders for 35
years or something like that.
And I flew a glider of
this type just recently.
That machine has a 49 to
one let's call it 50 to one
to make it easy, glide ratio.
Means if you're a mile above
the ground in still air,
you will go 50 miles before
you touch the ground.
So they're really amazing
high performance machines.
One of the things about all
aircraft that you actually
need to know is, you
really need to know where
the center of mass of it is.
And if the center of mass
is in the wrong place
the plane will not fly properly.
And so you can't just go
throw on 50 pounds of lead
in the tail of that
plane and expect
to survive the next flight.
So you have to know
where the center of mass
is, and in fact, you
want the center of mass
about 25% of the-- if the
wing is this wide from front
to back it's called the cord.
About 25% back from
the leading edge
is about where the center
of lift of a wing is.
And you want your
center of mass also
called the center of
gravity in these situations,
you want it to be pretty
close to the center of lift
so that their balance in
the plane flies nicely.
So is there a simple way to find
the center of mass of something
like a sailplane?
So I'm going to drew-- this
is exactly how you do it.
So I'll draw a quick picture
of my sailplane here.
You usually have a little skid
or a tail wheel on the back.
And to find the center of mass
you just set them on scales.
You weigh it.
You pick a coordinate system.
Doesn't matter where it
is, as long as it's fixed.
The easiest place is right
at the nose of the sailplane.
So we'll make this
x, make this y.
You take it and you
can take a tape measure
and measure the distance
from your reference point
to the position where the
wheel sits on the scales.
We'll call that L1 here.
And that's typically
about five feet.
And back here you
have another position
to where you have your second
set of scales, that's L2.
And a typical sailplane
that's about 15 feet.
Apply Newton's law.
This thing's not going anywhere.
Sum of the forces in
the vertical direction
is equal to 0.
Free body diagram.
Well you have somewhere about
here, where the wing is,
this is your center of mass.
And you have m total
times g downwards there.
You have two weights
pushing on the sailplane.
A W2 pushing up,
holding up the tail.
And a W1 holding
up the main gear.
And so from the sum of the
forces in the y-direction,
that had better be 0.
So you know that W1
plus W2 minus mtg is 0.
And so you find out that the
total weight of the sailplane
is no surprise, the sum of
the two weights on the scales.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let's do this, m, t, g.
So the total weight
times gravity
is just the sum of the two
readings on the scales.
And the second piece that you
need to do to do this problem
is, you can have an
equation that says,
the sum of the external
torques with respect
to you're-- through
a fixed point O,
is equal to the mass moment
of inertia times the angular
acceleration, oftentimes
written as alpha.
In this case, that's going
to be 0, it's going nowhere.
So what are the external torques
with respect to this point?
Well we have a right-handed
coordinate system.
You have W1 up, times L1.
W2 up, times L2
minus W1 plus W2,
which is the total weight
of the sailplane times
rg, the location of
the center of mass.
That's this distance
that we're looking for.
So we know everything
here, except rg.
So we can solve for
rg with respect to O
and it's simply W1 L1 plus
W2 L2 over W1 plus W2.
And if you run the numbers,
typically W1 600 pounds,
W2 the numbers I've done
here is-- might be 40 pounds.
And I've already said
five feet and 15 feet.
And you work the
answer and you come up
with 5.62 feet, which puts
this-- here is the wheel
and you're a little bit
aft of the main gear.
And that's where you,
basically where you want to be.
That's a real practical use of
knowing about centers of mass
and how to calculate them.
So that's the second item I
wanted to talk about today.
Essentially a recap
of the center of mass.
And now I want to
move on to talking
about a serious
introduction to-- we've
had the introduction,
velocities and accelerations.
We have to have a
way of writing down
the acceleration of a mass,
a point, a dog in a rotating,
translating, reference
frame with the possibility
that in addition to
that, the dog's moving.
So we want to have equations--
we want to have the ability
to write down expressions
for the velocity
and acceleration of a mass
moving in a translating,
rotating, reference frame.
So we've started this.
We did pretty much did
velocities to begin with.
So here's my inertial frame.
Call it O or O x, y, z.
Here's my rigid body out there.
It has a point a something
else, b might be the dog.
And we've described
the position of this
as the position of this
point a, with respect to O.
And at this point we're going
to locate a reference frame
attached to the rigid body.
And so it's going
to be called a,
and I'll call it x
prime, y prime, z prime.
It's attached to
the rigid body, it
rotates with the rigid
body and its attached
at some fixed point.
Now what would
oftentimes would be
a smart choice for that
fixed point at point A?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If you're going to
write an equation expressing
the motion of this.
Where would you make point a?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Center of mass.
PROFESSOR: Center of mass.
So very, very often, especially
when objects are free
floating around out there you're
going to make smart choices
and you're going to put
this coordinate system
right on the center of mass.
But it doesn't have
to be, but it can be.
So we were interested
in knowing things
about the motion of this point
in our inertial reference
frame, in terms of positions
of our coordinate system.
And then also this vector
here rd, with respect to a.
Now last time we came up with
expressions for the velocity
of b with respect to O.
We said in general it's the
velocity of your-- where
your coordinate
system's located.
The translating-- the velocity
of the translating frame
plus the derivative of
rba, time derivative
of the position as seen from,
if you were sitting at a.
And another way to
say that, or this
is a derivative taken with the
rotation rate momentarily set
equal to 0.
Another way to think of it.
Plus a piece that
comes from rotation.
So the rotation with respect
to the fixed frame, these
are all vectors, the
rotation with respect
to the fixed frame, cross
product with r, b, a.
And this-- and we
said this is actually
a general formula for the
derivative of-- this piece is
the derivative of a vector
in a frame, in a fixed frame.
You have two pieces,
the derivative as
seen without rotation
plus the contribution that
comes from rotation.
When I did this center of
mass thing a second ago,
I just kind of quickly wrote
down two time derivatives
of the position vector.
There's no omega cross
O's in there right?
Why could I do that?
This is actually kind of an
important distinct point.
I could do that they didn't say
very specifically when I did it
was an assumption I was making.
Except for perhaps they drew it.
This was done in a
Cartesian coordinate system.
And my coordinates
were x, y and z
and the unit vectors were
i, j, k and do they move?
No.
What's their time derivative?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: When you don't-- when
the inner vectors don't have
time derivatives you
don't get these terms.
This is the only term that
contributes so I could just
write that equation.
But we now have a reference
frame attached to a body
and this reference
frame is rotating.
And that means that the
direction of the unit vectors
attach-- the unit vector
attached to x-prime here
is moving, it's rotating.
And it's going to have
a time derivative.
So we have to--
and that is given
and you take those
time derivatives you
get this second piece.
I'm going to give you
the answer in advance.
The acceleration of b
with respect to O I'm
going to give you
the full 3D equation.
Then we'll go back and see
a bit where it comes from.
So here's-- it's the time
derivative of that velocity
expression with respect to time
taken in the inertial frame O,
x, y, z.
And am I going to have
enough room to get this on?
It'll be close.
All right this has
several pieces.
It's got a contribution of the
acceleration of a with respect
to O. That's just the
acceleration of this point.
Has nothing to do with rotation,
so it's just a straight out
acceleration of my translating
frame with respect to O.
That's the first piece.
The second piece is related-- is
the derivative of this guy that
comes from the
derivative of this.
It's the acceleration of b
with respect to a as seen
in this a frame.
If you read the
Williams book, it's
called the relative
acceleration.
It's relative to the-- if
you were sitting at point A,
it's what you would see
as the acceleration.
Plus 2 omega cross
velocity of b with respect
to a as seen from a plus
omega dot, the derivative
of the rotation rate,
cross rba plus omega cross,
omega cross r, b, a.
Kind of daunting right?
A little messy.
Basically one, two, three,
four, five different terms.
And you're going to-- and they
all have names and meanings.
And one of the things
that will really help you
is to get familiar,
you really need
to be familiar with the meaning
of each one of the terms.
And it's not terribly difficult.
This one, just the acceleration
of the translating frame.
So if it's a
merry-go-round sitting
on a train and the train's
heading down the track,
its acceleration of the train.
Rotating frame is attached
to the merry-go-round.
And if you've got the
dog on the merry-go-round
this is then the acceleration
of the dog relative to this,
the merry-go-round.
This position of the
coordinate system
attached to the merry-go-round
has no rotation in it.
This is the velocity
of that point, the dog,
as seen from the A frame.
Again, you have no
sense of rotation.
Rotation is not a part of this.
Cross product with
the rotation rate.
This is the accelerate.
This is the angular acceleration
cross product with rba.
Now that's a term--
what does that mean?
I'm swinging a baseball bat and
I'm accelerating this thing.
Idealize it as just something
on a radius accelerating.
The acceleration
of a point out here
is the radius times the
angular acceleration.
So that's all this term is.
And it's called the
Euler acceleration.
But it's just simply
r theta double dot.
This, if you multiply it out
and just think about units,
this ends up looking
like r omega squared.
Have you run into that before?
What's that?
Common language.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's as a
centrifugal-- centripetal,
this is centripetal
acceleration.
So this is the centripetal
acceleration term,
that's the Euler
this is the local acceleration.
This is the acceleration
of your frame.
This is the strange one.
This is the Coriolis
acceleration.
And we'll get
familiar with it too.
So that's the full blown
3D acceleration equation.
And by the way the
vector-- the velocity one
is also perfect 3D.
Now in this course we won't do
much in the way of 3D dynamics
problems.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the point
b on the rigid plane move?
PROFESSOR: Does the-- it may.
It could be this is the-- an
asteroid out there in space
and you've got--
this is home base
and that's a guy out there
in a space suit running.
So we want to be
able to describe
the acceleration of that guy
as seen from a fixed reference
frame.
Now why would we want to
know that acceleration?
Why do we want to know
it in a fixed frame?
Well if you want to calculate
the forces on the person.
Well how much-- what's he
have to do with his feet
to brace himself or whatever?
What are the actual forces?
You have to know the
acceleration on the person.
But Newton's laws, in
order to say f equals ma,
Newton's laws have to be applied
in inertial reference frames.
Is this thing out there doing
this an a inertial reference
frame?
No.
So you can't
calculate the forces
without having some idea
of this inertial frame.
So this is the way of
getting the acceleration
on-- at a location on a moving,
rotating body with respect
to an inertial frame.
And with all the terms present.
Now most discourse has
generally has addressed problems
which are in most textbooks
address only planar motion
problems.
Planar motion basically
means that we can find
the translations to a plane.
So imagine an x, and a y, and
a z upwards coordinate system
attached to the top this table.
And I only allow motions
that are around the table.
And I only allow motions that
have a single axis rotation.
And that's lined up with z.
Those are essentially
planar motion problems.
And most courses in dynamics,
it lists [INAUDIBLE].
That's as far as they get.
And the most of the
problems that you'll do
will be planar motion problems.
But that equation reduces to the
planar motion problem as well.
We will do a little bit
of 3D, because there's
a class of problems
that I really
think it's important for you
to understand that just come up
all the time that
require a little 3D.
And as you want to have
some things going on
out of the plane,
but we'll still
confine the axis of rotation
to a single direction.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in a planar,
but then would you have three to
view the freedom? [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
a great question
she said if you
had a dog running
on the merry-go-round how many
degrees of freedom do you have?
So in general rigid
bodies, each rigid body,
each independent
rigid body has--
you have to describe its
location of its center of mass
and that takes how
many coordinates?
How many coordinates
I'll call them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well
in general three.
And it can now rotate
around three different axes.
And that takes three more.
So rigid bodies have
six degrees of freedom.
And any problem when you go
to address the problem you
essentially for a rigid
body you start with six.
And you start
applying constraints
to reduce it down to
the number of remaining
degrees of freedom.
So if it's confined to
a plane and no z-motion
is allowed one constraint.
If it is on a
plane and it's only
allowed to rotate
about the z-axis that
means you've constrained its
rotation in around y and x.
So that's two more.
And so now you're down to three
degrees of freedom left, xy
and a rotation about the z-axis.
So planar motion
problems generally
have three degrees of freedom.
But instant-- let's
just say we're
just interested in
just something that
rotates and doesn't translate.
How many degrees of freedom
does that have then?
Just one.
x and y are forced not
to-- no motion, two more
constraints you're down to one.
So lots of problems we do
are in fact single degree
of freedom problems.
So to do planar motion
problems we oftentimes
use polar coordinates.
So I'm going to
introduce r theta.
And I'm actually going to call
it cylindrical coordinates.
And cylindrical coordinates then
you have an r, a theta and z.
And let's think about well
let's see, I have a demo,
a little demo here.
So here's a problem with
a single axis of rotation.
And it's a-- there is a mass out
here and just this is a rhyme.
And so think of this
think of this mass
out here as being a bug
walking out this rod.
And the rod, this thing
goes round and round.
It's not a
merry-go-round but it's
a merry-go-round with
a gang plank on it.
It's going up at
an angle and you
can walk the gang plank
while the merry-go-round's
going around.
So that's what we got here.
So this is actually allowed to
change position of this mass.
So how would I describe that
with cylindrical coordinates?
Let me so it's going to take--
one would be a side view.
So you see your
vertical axis here
and have to have a bearing
to hold it in place.
Here's the arm, here's the
bug walking out the arm,
has some rotation rate.
Theta dot this is the z-axis
and the position of this point
is described by a r
vector, in the r hat
direction, which I
think is the unit
vectors you're used to using.
And then this is the z-component
in the k hat direction.
And this vector here would be r
of v with respect to what shall
I call it?
I'll make this a and
over here someplace
I have a fixed inertial let's
see I got to be careful here.
I want that to be z then I
have a y going out here x, y, z
pointing upwards.
And my-- this fixed
inertial system the unit
vectors here this would
be i hat, j hat and k hat.
But these-- this rotating
system with its unit
vector little k and this
vector they're the same,
they're parallel.
But looking down on this, this
is my polar coordinate system.
Now I'm going to
look at my top view.
I will see a projection.
I'll just see the
r, this is rr hat,
this is my point
B. This is theta.
And I have a unit vector.
So the unit vector r hat is
something-- the unit long
pointing in this direction.
And the unit vector in this
direction is theta hat.
And it's perpendicular
to that radius.
So now I have my
three unit vectors.
One pointing in the
direction of r, here's
also my unit vector is just to
make sure there's no confusion.
This unit vector is
in this direction.
K is in that direction.
Theta is in that direction.
And over here you still
have your-- now here's
my x, y, z out of the
board inertial frame.
And this-- my inertial
frame this might be r, b, o.
So in my inertial frame.
I want to know
what's going on here.
I want to be able to
calculate the velocities
and the accelerations.
So the notation here gets--
can get a little confusing.
The rbo notation that
I've been using all along,
that's the motion-- that's
the position vector describing
that point in my inertial frame.
And my-- just lowercase r here,
no scrub scripts or anything,
that's just going to-- that's
my polar coordinate r theta
and z that happened
to be in this case,
this is a rotating frame.
This is a rotating frame.
It's the center of this
coordinate system's at a.
But this thing rotates.
So this is a pretty
simplified version
of this general problem.
Now because it's simplified,
you can actually--
it's a lot easier to use.
Also has some real limitations.
You can only going just--
there's limited things
that you can describe with it.
So let's start by describing
velocities in cylindrical
coordinates.
Remember this rba is the
length of this guy here.
And it's made up
of rr hat zk hat.
So to express the
velocity we have
to take a time derivative
of this r, b, a
and I'm going to express
it in terms of r theta nz.
And to get acceleration
I have to take two time
derivatives of this, but
this is going to be expressed
in my cylindrical coordinates.
This is where I'm going.
And lots of problems--
many, many of these problems
have fixed axes of
rotations and this velocity
and this acceleration are zero.
You just drop it out.
I'm going to do that
just to keep this-- make
this problem a little simpler.
So we can just focus
on these terms.
So let's just let the there be
no translational of this frame.
And that says that
Va with respect
to O the acceleration of A
with respect to O over zero.
So I want you to just
focus on these terms.
I don't lose anything,
I can put these back in
later if I need them.
I just don't want to
keep carrying them along.
So I have my--
remember my side view.
This is r, r hat zk
hat that's my point.
And my top view.
This is my projection
just looking down on it
what I see is the length r.
And what I see in my unit vector
going that way r direction
and theta that direction.
And this is x and the
i and a y with a j hat
vector looking down on it.
My rotation rate mega with
respect to my inertial frame,
is sum theta dot k hat.
All right so now let's find
the velocity of b with respect
to O. Well it's 0, no
translation, plus--
and now I need a time derivative
of rb with respect to a.
But this is then r, b, a
is r, r hat plus z k hat.
And I need the time
derivative of that.
So I get an r dot r hat plus
an r r hat dot plus a z dot k.
So this is the
product of two things.
They're both time dependent.
So I have to get two pieces, k
does not change in direction.
So it has no time derivative.
So I only have a z dot k.
So this is a result
of doing this,
but I now have to
figure out what
is the time derivative of the
unit vector in the r direction.
So when I told-- when we worked
out this formula the other day
for the time derivative
of a rotating vector,
I mostly did it, it was kind
of an intuitive argument.
So on this one
occasion I'm going
to give you an example
of actually figuring out
what the derivative of
this rotating vector is.
And if you go read
that kinematics handout
and it does this in kind of full
blown form for-- in general.
So I'm just going to
do it as one example.
So here's our looking down on
this, the projection on the xy
plane, here's our r-vector.
And here's this
unit vector and it
starts from-- I have a unit
vector starting from a it's
unit-- it's one long.
And this is r hat.
And it's of unit length and it's
in this particular direction.
Now in a little bit it
time delta t, it moves.
It moves to here.
So this is delta r hat and
what direction does it move?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it moves in
the-- moves in the theta hat
direction.
And the amount that it
moves is the rotation rate,
theta dot, delta t.
So delta r hat, if I
solve for this, delta t.
And this is in the
theta hat direction,
is theta dot theta hat.
So this is the
limit as t, delta t
goes to 0 you get the derivative
of r hat with respect to time.
Its direction is in
the theta hat direction
and its magnitude is theta dot.
So that's the time derivative
of the unit vector r hat.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How does
that work with units?
PROFESSOR: How does
it work with units?
What's left out of here is
that this is unit length
and has dimensions.
It's unit length, one whatever
unit system you're working.
So that is implicitly in here.
It's one meter theta dot and
that theta dot, the delta t,
the times go away.
You're left with one meter times
the magnitude of theta dot.
So the distance
it actually moves
is r theta, the r delta theta,
delta theta is theta dot delta
t and the radius
happens to be 1.
So whatever unit system you're
working in it's a unit vector.
Has unit length.
So its units are
buried right there.
Good question.
OK so now we know what this is.
So now we can come back finish
our description of the velocity
of b with respect to
a then is r dot r hat
plus z dot k hat
plus theta dot times
so r times the derivative of
the unit vector r, which we just
figured out is theta
dot theta hat times r.
R theta dot theta hat.
So that's my velocity
of b with respect to a.
My velocity of B with respect
to O all you have to add in
is the velocity of A
with perspective to O,
which we've let be 0 for now.
So for the moment this is
also d with respect to O.
But this is the general
piece of the velocity
of b with respect to a in
polar cylindrical coordinates.
Now we could have-- so I've
actually worked it out, just
shown you, just drew the picture
and figured out the derivative.
We could have used
that magic formula.
The formula for the derivative
of a vector in a rotating
frame.
So I'll just do that
quickly to remind you
how we could have done this.
rba with respect to time
as seen in the O frame.
Is the partial derivative
of rba with respect
to time as seen in the rotating
frame, plus omega cross r, b,
a.
This term is that and that.
The derivative of
this rba as seen
from inside of the
rotating frame,
is just the change in length,
this is rba here from the side.
So the change in length of
that vector, the derivative
of-- the time derivative of it.
It's the vector sum of
the r dot plus z dot.
So this piece comes
from this and this.
And this piece should-- this
one here, it better be this.
Well this is--
let's figure it out.
This is omega in
the k hat direction,
cross and rba is r
r hat plus z k hat.
k cross k is 0.
k cross r theta hat.
K cross-- k hat cross r
hat is theta hat positive.
r omega theta hat, same thing
as r theta dot theta hat.
So we could have just applied
this formula for the derivative
of a rotating
vector and we would
have gotten the same thing.
OK just ran out of boards.
Now a quick little exercise
you could do on your own
is, we're going to need
to be able to calculate
the derivative of theta hat.
Well just plug it in
that little formula.
And the first term you'll find
out the derivative of the theta
hat, the length doesn't change
in time, it's a unit vector.
So you only have
the second piece.
So it's sum omega cross
theta and you're going
to get minus theta dot r hat.
So I really want to get here.
The acceleration
of b and O. That's
the real-- that's the
single piece we really
need to finish the kinematics.
So we can do most any problems.
Got to be able to describe
the acceleration of a point
and translating rotating frame.
And that's going to be the
acceleration of a with respect
to O, plus a time derivative of
the velocity of b with respect
to O.
We've calculated
the velocity, we
need to be able to essentially
carry out this derivative.
Two time derivatives of the
r, b, a, or a single time
derivative of bva.
Well we just
computed the velocity
in this-- of this
rotating frame and this
is our final expression.
So we need to compute the
time derivative of that.
I just-- so it's
going to look like r
dot r hat plus over here a
term r theta dot theta hat
and pardon me for
doing this I think
it'll be cleaner in the end.
I'm going to start with my
z dot k, keep it over here,
plus r dot r hat plus this term.
And this is going to
take up a lot room.
Just spread out this way so it--
So let's just-- I'm going to
write down where this comes
out, this is a little
tedious, but then you'll
have seen it once hopefully
believe that it really works.
So these terms, this
first term here just
gives you z double dot.
So let's write her down.
So just z double dot k hat
time derivative of this,
plus an r double
dot r hat, but now I
have to take-- do it, flip it
and do the other side of it.
So I get my-- how do
I want to do this?
Yeah, I like this.
So this term kept--
leads to this.
This term brings you to here.
This term, you get r dot times
theta dot theta hat plus an r
and now you need to take a time
derivative of theta dot theta
hat.
So that's going to expand.
So this brings you to here.
Now we've done this derivative,
so we can put it in.
So this gives us
this term over here,
so let's keep adding these up.
Notice this gives me an r
dot theta dot theta hat.
This gives me an r dot
theta dot theta hat.
Two identical terms.
Now this term gives me an r
theta double dot theta hat.
And now this-- now
we need to take
the derivative of theta
hat and that gives you
minus theta dot r hat.
So you get a minus r but
multiplied by theta dot again
squared r hat.
So I think we're about there.
We're going to start
collecting things together.
Now we have a two
r dot theta dot
theta hat plus an r theta double
dot theta hat, minus r theta
dot squared r half.
So these things,
these derivatives,
just all kind of flowed
down and led to more terms.
But now if we compare-- that
we get one, two, three, four,
five, I clump these together.
This is the change in
length of the r vector.
Stretch in the position has a
z component and a r component.
This is the movement of the
coordinate system if it moves.
This is the Coriolis term.
This is the Euler
acceleration and this is
the centripetal acceleration.
So this is the--
what happens when
you start with that
messy vector thing
and apply it, restrict it to a
cylindrical coordinate problem,
which is basically
planar motion.
But you allow some things
in the z direction only.
So polar coordinates is a
more limited form of that,
but it's-- every
term comes back,
every term is still in it.
So acceleration of
the moving coordinate
system, change of the
length of the position
vector in the moving
coordinate system,
the Coriolis term the Euler
acceleration term that angular
acceleration speedup and
finally the centripetal term.
Now the way you go
about solving problems,
usins-- doing problems
in polar coordinates.
So now you're asked to
find an equation of motion.
This is an expression
for the acceleration
of whatever it is you're
trying to describe
in an inertial frame.
So that when you say-- you
can now say f equals ma.
If you know the--
sometimes you're
given the forces in
problems and your asked
to find the accelerations.
But what if you're
given the acceleration
and you're asked
to find the force?
All right, I give you the
simplest problem of this kind.
What's the tension
in the string?
Well if I know
that-- so I just say,
the way you do these problems
is how many things can you
eliminate?
Well I wasn't moving,
this term goes away.
That's zero.
Z wasn't involved,
it's not changing,
it's just constant angular
rotation, that term is 0.
What's the change in length
of the string while I
was doing it?
Now if that term's 0 we're
getting easier all time.
How far-- how fast was
the length getting longer?
That terms gone away.
Was I speeding up, or slowing
down, or constant speed?
Well we'll say it's
constant speed,
ooh this problem's getting
easier all the time.
I'm down to one term.
f equals ma.
Minus r theta dot squared r hat.
So the force that I must have
been applying to the string
was in the minus r
hat direction and had
magnitude mr omega squared.
So that's actually
all there is to it.
We're using polar coordinates
and cylindrical coordinates
to do second law problems.
So there's a couple of
problems that you're
doing these kind of
things on the homework
set that's being put out today.
So give them a try.
Have a good weekend.